oh my god i feel like nicole kidman and
moulin rouge
everyone is talking about netflix's
emily in paris
love it or hate it this show has become
our latest obsession
are you looking for more emily in paris
after binging the whole season
well you've come to the right place
we've got all the behind the scenes
tidbits to get you through your emily
and paris withdrawal
from filming secrets you didn't know
about to memorable off-screen moments
between the cast
you'll love this peek at what went on
behind the scenes of this netflix hit
this is a very important shoot i'm just
going to be getting some behind the
scenes for social in the states
the look that emily rocks to the opera
is an homage to audrey hepburn
emily looks stunning in this christian
soriano dress
that she wears to the palace garnier
opera house in episode 6.
the look was a deliberate homage to
audrey hepburn in funny face
in which she gracefully walks down the
very same steps of the garnier opera
that emily does it helps that lily
collins is a dead ringer for audrey and
she definitely embodies the glamour that
audrey hepburn lived
and breathed the crew had the opera
house all to themselves for filming
which makes this moment
extra special there were so many camera
angles and camera shots to get within
the scene to kind of amplify the beauty
of the location
remember the dress emily wears you know
the dress
the gorgeous white gown she models at
the designer auction in episode nine
only for it to get art attacked by paint
well lily collins actually got to keep
the iconic dress
the dress was designed by french fashion
designer stephanie roland who actually
designed all the beautiful dresses in
the designer showroom
after they filmed the show roland sent
lily a clean version of the dress to
keep
we're more than a little jealous this
was the most important for me
to bring lightness to women we all know
that emily in paris takes place in
well paris duh it's right there in the
title but did you know that the entire
show was
actually shot on location in paris and
the nearby loire valley
according to lily collins it's also the
first american show that's completely
shot in paris
so all those iconic landmarks you see
the characters hanging around
are the real deal we love the show's
commitment to shooting where it's
actually set
for me the luckiest thing about shooting
there was the access to the incredible
locations that we got
it adds a dose of authenticity that
can't be replicated
and turns the show into a true love
letter to the city of paris
paris seems like a big city but it's
really just a small town
unlike emily who doesn't speak a lick of
french and relies on an app to translate
for her
lily collins was practically fluent in
french growing up she would read speak
and even dream in french but she stopped
practicing years ago
and lost much of the language but being
back in paris for the show had her
dreaming in french again
despite her character being hopelessly
bad at it lily even said play a
character that
hardly understands the language at all
it was very difficult for me
and then switch into totally speaking
french creator darren starr wanted his
writer's room to have the same
experience
emily goes through as a fish out of
water seeing paris for the first time
to ground the show in lived reality so
he sent his writers to live in and
experience the city first hand
it must have been quite the treat for
those who had never been and even though
the storyline had been planned out ahead
much of the actual writing for the
series happened on the ground when they
were in paris
getting cast on emily in paris must have
been a dream for star lily collins but
it also coincided with the opportunity
to work with director david fincher on
his upcoming netflix film
mank collins flew back and forth between
paris and los
angeles to attend mank rehearsals
juggling both projects at the same time
that meant that on a couple of occasions
she had to fly back to la
on the weekend for a 24-hour period and
then immediately fly back and go
straight to set for emily
as she put it i was in the air longer
than i was on the ground during those
crazy weekends anyway it's not just
about the number of followers
it's about content emily's amazing phone
case that looks like an old-school
camera belonged to costume designer
patricia field
she picked it up on a trip to korea lily
collins loved it and
insisted on making it a part of the
character who loves all things fashion
and photography
you know we are all a little afraid of
you
what it ended up being an identifying
character piece
similar to carrie bradshaw's necklace
creator darren starr wasn't totally into
the idea at first but field knew it
would work
she was right the phone case is super
chic and we'd love to know where we can
find one for ourselves
even when you're very hungry
in fact a number of pieces in emily's
wardrobe came from patricia field's
personal closet
field who is known for her amazing work
on sex than the city and the devil wears
prada didn't like some of the wardrobe
choices available to her so she simply
let lilly collins use some of her own
personal clothing items
in particular she lent her mcm backpack
and hood by air jacket to the character
when you have items this fashionable why
not use them we think it's cool patricia
field got to lend such a personal touch
to emily's style
oh um can i get a big one like cashmere
darren starr the genius behind the show
also created sex in the city and carrie
bradshaw's influence on emily is
noticeable
star also worked closely with patricia
field on sex in the city
naturally they paid homage to the show
through outfits and design choices
in one episode for instance emily wears
a pair of earrings that spell her name
which is an homage to carrie bradshaw's
carry necklace
other little references are made through
some of emily's outfits like the black
tool skirt she wears that reminds us of
carrie's signature tutu
never mind sorry it's a long story lily
collins believes that emily herself took
a lot of inspiration from carrie
bradshaw
saying i think she took into
consideration if carrie went to france
what would she wear
what would she do on top of that we
can't help but think emily's experience
of coming to paris mirrors the time that
carrie visited paris in the final season
of sex in the city
right down to filming in the iconic
hotel plaza athene
where carrie bradshaw stayed in the
series finale there's no doubt emily had
carrie on her mind when she visited this
beautiful parisian building
i grew up loving saxon city love carrie
bradshaw
darren starr thinks he subconsciously
picked the name emily because he loved
how the french pronounce
emily emily
and of course we can't think of the name
emily without thinking of the film
emily which is about a native but
imaginative parisian girl named
emily both emily in paris and the film
emily
shared a romanticized but whimsical
approach to the city so we can't help
but think it played a part in choosing
the name
and speaking of names emily's friend
mindy was named after a real friend of
darren stars
who lives in paris you can't have a show
set in paris without a dreamy french
love interest
and boy does lucas bravo succeed in that
role as the hot chef gabriel
you're the chef here wait is there a
problem
according to darren starr bravo was put
through the ringer before landing the
role
having to come back and audition
multiple times it wasn't until he came
back and did an audition with lily
collins that the deal was sealed
their chemistry was too good to deny and
it
shows i'm gonna miss you so much and i
the cast hung out and went wine tasting
in between scenes shot in the loire
valley
lucas bravo mentions that between scenes
we went wine tasting because there was a
vineyard nearby
in general the cast got to shop and
whine and dine in and around paris
just like their characters we can't
blame them for taking advantage of being
in paris of all places
the amazing behind the scenes photos
that the cast has shared on social media
have us
itching to catch a plane straight to
paris and never leave
it's perfect it's perfect
we love when actors rub off on the
characters they play in tv shows
and get to influence the writing one
example is that mindy wasn't supposed to
be a singer until ashley park was cast
ashley park has an amazing voice which
she showed off as gretchen and mean
girls the musical
darren starr loved her and her voice so
much that he made it a part of mindy's
character
he says he selfishly just wanted to hear
her voice but we're all thankful for it
i guess i thought you wouldn't
understand bonding is inevitable when
you spend so much time together with
your cast mates on a once in a lifetime
experience like this one
and the emily in paris cast is no
exception the cast really bonded and
became best friends while shooting
and they've shared little tidbits from
the set on social media like these funny
faces lucas bravo makes
into the camera in between takes
secretly captured by ashley park
and even though lucas and ashley barely
have any scenes together
the two lived next to each other while
filming and became inseparable
it looks like the cast of emily and
paris had the time of their lives
shooting this show and how could they
not being immersed in the city of love
did you enjoy these behind the scenes
moments from netflix's latest hit
leave a comment below and don't forget
to subscribe for more awesome videos
a la prochaine